good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday and I'm in an airport yay so
Hank a couple days ago I was talking to
a nerdfighter named Naomi and she said
that we should bring back the evil baby
orphanage and I was like I don't know
maybe the world doesn't need an evil
baby orphanage and then North Korea
launched a long-range missile into the
ocean Hank it's time to bring back the
evil baby orphanage so as you know the
evil baby orphanage is a fairly
straightforward idea that was invented
almost two years ago by a nerdfighter
named Brooke as a way of resolving an
argument that nerdfighters were having
over whether or not we should go back in
time and kill the evil baby Hitler
Brooke came up with a compromise
solution in which we would go back in
time kidnap evil baby Hitler and then
take him to the evil baby orphanage
which would be a school designed
explicitly for evil babies in like Tibet
or something well Hank I don't need to
tell you how good an idea the evil baby
orphanage is the problem in the end
wasn't that we found it difficult to
build a time machine the problem was
that you and I had a profound
disagreement over the nature of time
travel paradoxes a disagreement which
continues to this day but Hank I think
it's time for us to put aside our petty
squabble because the world needs an evil
baby orphanage now Hank I know that it's
tempting to say that North Korea
launching a rocket into the ocean isn't
particularly impressive I could launch a
rocket into the ocean if I wanted to but
Hank there are a couple of important
differences between North Korea and me
first off I'm not run by a crazy 68 year
old Korean grandmother named Kim jong-il
what's that really are you sure Hank I
have some important breaking news Kim
jong-il is apparently a dude but yeah so
first I'm not run by a crazy dude and
second I don't have nuclear weapons even
though the launch was what is
technically known as an epic fail the
international community is still really
mad even China's mad it's like when you
go completely crazy and all your friends
abandoned you except for one friend who
kind of stays with you because she's
also completely crazy and then finally
she's like dear North Korea I love your
totalitarianism and I think you've got
an awesome cult of personality and it's
great how you never let people leave
your country and you kill your political
enemies but come on
UTF best wishes China now Hank I'm not
going to tell you that we need to get
Kim jong-il into the evil baby orphanage
he's just a fat crazy dude we need to
get his dead dad Kim il-sung into the
evil baby orphanage so that Kim jong-il
never exists getting Kim il-sung into
the evil baby orphanage would save
literally millions of lives and restore
Korea to a single unified country what
we'd have to build a time machine that
that shouldn't be a challenge I mean
nerdfighters do everything that we ask
them to do
they ate 317 peeps for me you don't
think they can build a time machine get
your head out of your ass sorry I got
them into curse but this guy over here
telling me what nerdfighters can't do is
really getting on my nerves I mean you
call me when you built upon sand filter
in Bangladesh tank you'll see me on
Tuesday the people in the airport think
that I'm crazy the people in the airport
think that I'm crazy